[Music]
the 18th century the age of reason was a
time of hospital building
[Music]
trying to heal the sick man in his
ignorance had devised a reservoir of
sepsis
[Music]
a few perceptive physicians observed
that uncleanliness overcrowding and
failure to isolate infectious patients
encourage the spread of disease
[Music]
following pastors discoveries in the mid
19th century
the realization came that such hospital
conditions spread disease because they
spread organisms we began to grope for
new techniques to control disease the
age of antisepsis had begun Joseph
Lister stands out among the pioneers of
that century it was he who said you must
be able to see with your mental eye the
septic ferments as distinctly as we see
flies or other insects with a corporeal
eye if you can really see them in this
distinct way with your intellectual eye
you can be properly on your guard
against them this was our temper when
the 20th century came in we had learned
to see Lister septic ferments with our
mental eye our understanding had
minimized cross infection we were on our
guard and today since the therapeutic
revolution of antibiotics we rely too
much on antibiotics and not enough on a
sepsis our guard is down liberal
visiting privileges and division of
labour have pyramid the number of people
who contact the patient and crowd the
corridors each exchanges bacteria with
the patients and with each other
once again many of our hospitals are
reservoirs of uncontrolled infection
because of the complication of
antibiotic resistance and the source of
hospital sepsis originally it is this
the infected patient
mrs. Sarah Allen had had a 10-year
history of boils and pimples she was
hospitalized eventually to discover the
cause of the continued skin sepsis the
staphylococci which caused her
difficulty were alien to the hospital
and it was this fact that made her
useful in tracing the spread of
infection a single room was disinfected
for this particular investigation the
walls were sprayed with germicidal
detergent and squeegee dry the furniture
was washed with germicide and the
bedding sterilized the floor was flooded
with detergent germicide and the film of
water picked up with a vacuum cleaner
after disinfection cultures were taken
of the bedding floor in the air the
environment prepared to house mrs.
Allen's organisms was relatively aseptic
cultures were taken again after 24 hours
of occupancy the technique of culturing
the bedding was simply to press it
against the medium the floor was
cultured by swabbing a given area the
septic solution was then mixed with a
culture medium the air was cultured by
using a weld centrifuge which passes a
measured quantity of air into a tube
centrifugal action throws dust and
bacteria against the medium on the wall
of the tube
these bacteria accumulated during the
first 24 hours of occupancy
Raaj typing identified the bacteria
isolated in the experiment the
translucent spots in the fourth square
of each upper row indicate that bacteria
from all cultures were destroyed by 579
this confirmed the source of organisms
as being mrs. Allan cultures were taken
on subsequent days
this was the appearance of the cultures
taken on day seven
the rise in the count of bacteria per
square inch on bedding from admission
through the seventh day was this the
floor count per square centimeter the
air count per five cubic feet
there was no moisture in mrs. Allen
surroundings and hence no place for
organisms to multiply the rise in
bacteria during the seven days therefore
represents an accumulation only the air
counts charted here are averages however
throughout a given day the variation
during different activities is
significant an air sample taken while
the bed is being made gives a better
idea of the increase in the room's
bacterial population
bed-making contributes a remarkable
number of organisms to the surrounding
air during the period of no activity the
count was eleven bacteria per five cubic
feet of air during bed making 160 or
more other cultures showed this rise and
fall
here the patient straightens her
bedcovers and the period of no activity
in the evening what part of the patient
precisely is the source of the
accumulating organisms
evidently mrs. Allen's carbuncles are
only local manifestations of systemic
bacterial disease she is shedding
bacteria from her whole person this
becomes obvious when we culture the
bathroom fixtures that she contacts
it becomes obvious when an infected
patient is allowed to leave an isolation
room
these are colonies of mrs. Allen's
organisms shed during the simple act of
walking by ordinary dressings do not
confine bacteria to the lesion moisture
seeps through the gauze evaporates and
leaves bacteria to be scattered as shown
by this culture of the outer surface of
mrs. Allen's dressing when a dressing is
handled carelessly it isn't hard to
visualize the spread of organisms to the
hands close and nose of the examiner the
physicians actions should set the
pattern for safe Hospital practices each
time he cares for his patient
another major source of organisms is the
spray from conversation and breathing in
slow motion the word pipette looks like
this
a conclusion of the investigation is
this the infected patient is the source
of hospital sepsis a readily
communicable disease isolation
techniques such as the use of
prepackaged sterile dressings masks
gowns an ultraviolet curtain
disinfection of shoes and hands are
essential to keep the bacteria within
the patient's room if not properly
confined bacteria can travel from the
source of infection by dozens of roots
they are carried by feet hands clothing
and noses they circulate by soiled linen
and improper ventilating systems they
are spread by blankets dressings tails
and mops by any article that enters and
leaves the room but the action of each
of these spreaders is not simply that of
carrying a few bacteria from an infected
patient to some other patient each also
becomes a reservoir and some of these
reservoirs may become serious
multipliers for instance a culture of
mop water taken at the end of the day
may not yield an overwhelming picture of
sepsis but the same water presents a
different picture the next morning
other common multipliers are damped
soiled linen dressings moist soap
bedside water the air conditioning
system and the nasopharynx
every hospital is a complex of possible
multipliers reservoirs and spreaders of
bacteria consider one of the many
possible trails bacteria spread from
nose to skin to clothing to floor where
they can live for long periods in the
dust the bacteria are picked up on a map
where overnight they multiply
bacteria from this rich new source are
painted generously throughout the
hospital the film of water dries the
bacteria are scuffed into the air they
may be carried into the air-conditioning
system from here they are fed back into
the entire ventilation complex as these
various processes go on with dozens of
inter woven multipliers and spreaders
gradually there is created a septic
environment the problem of each hospital
is to discover which multipliers and
spreaders are responsible for sepsis in
that particular Hospital steps can then
be taken to block the feedbacks at
various points there are practices
common to many hospitals that may be a
source of trouble mopping is one we will
mop mrs. Allen's floor from a pail
actually being used in another part of
the hospital on this day the water
contains only the usual detergent used
in this hospital
a culture was taken from the floor when
it was again dry here is a comparison
with the earlier culture taken before
mopping mops may leave more bacteria on
the floor than they remove because the
usual germicide is not effective in
large wads of text or it is better to
use a vacuum cleaner or treated cloth
still better results are obtained if the
floor can be flooded periodically with a
detergent germicide which is picked up
with a wet vacuum after this treatment a
culture demonstrates that for practical
purposes the floor is eliminated as a
source of bacteria
once the floor is properly treated the
bed remains as the principal reservoir a
typical bacterial count showed top sheet
160 pillow 176 and bottom sheet 240 by
comparison a clean sheet showed only 3.4
it is obvious that sheets and covers
should never be whisked into the air
when sheets are changed
relatively few bacteria are scattered if
the sheets are loosened and rolled up
soiled linen must be collected in a bag
and not removed until it is put in the
washer if soiled linen is carelessly
handled the trail of bacteria is not
hard to imagine
if sorting of linen is done before
washing the air becomes heavily loaded
for when the bacteria multiply in the
moist linens the concentration becomes
enormous these airborne organisms may
contaminate freshly washed linen and be
redistributed to the wards
also they are an occupational hazard for
the laundry worker soiled linen should
remain in the bags in which it has been
collected the laundry is then washed
just as it comes from the wards sorting
can be done after tumbling this means
the dressings and other trash must be
kept out of laundry bags
a germicidal textile lubricant added to
the final rinse will prevent the
multiplication of organisms as shown by
the culture of treated and untreated
linen swatches the area of inhibition
around the two treated swatches shows
the germicidal effectiveness of the
linen clean linen should be
redistributed in cupboard laundry trucks
and never in those used for collection
of soiled linen sanitary processing
during the laundry cycle can eliminate a
possibly serious trail of infection
another reservoir in which bacteria
await the next patient is the mattress
plastic covers protect mattresses and
pillows and make disinfection with a
long-acting germicide ez blankets
present a more serious problem this one
which was sterile when first put on has
been used by mrs. Allen for seven days
her organisms will contact the next
patient unless the blanket is again
sterilized another reservoir for
bacteria usually unsuspected is bedside
drinking water when a patient drinks
directly from a carafe or from a cup
which also serves as the lid saliva
contaminates the remaining water and
bacteria are free to multiply when this
carafe is collected with others to be
refilled and redistributed another
spreader is set loose in the hospital
one solution is the use of disposable
liners
tasteless odourless germicide should be
added to the water supply of ice makers
to maintain purity of the cubes during
distribution carafes should be filled
directly from a water tap there are many
other articles in the hospital that may
be responsible for transmitting bacteria
from a septic patient some are so
obvious that we routinely take special
precautions others such as soap however
are rarely suspect though soap is
actually a nutrient medium and can
become a hazardous feedback the air
itself is still another source of
trouble even if it were possible to
isolate all septic patients behind walls
many hospitals are so designed that it
is difficult to isolate patients from
each other's air and airborne bacteria
air which is often recirculated would
carry mrs. Allen's organisms to any room
serviced by the system but beyond this
simple spreading of bacteria an untended
air conditioner can also become a
multiplier bacteria grow in the moisture
on the refrigerator coils or in the
humidifying pan a few organisms going in
may return after a time as a cloud
this feedback can be checked by regular
maintenance baffles tend to accumulate
slime of bacteria they should be washed
periodically with a detergent germicide
also a bacterial agent should be added
to the humidifying water this treatment
prevents an air conditioner from
becoming a multiplier though any system
that recirculates air may broadcast the
available organisms the whims of air
currents however are not as simple as
this ventilating systems distribute air
under positive or negative pressure open
doors and windows caused it to flow
unpredictably
if doorways are left open in stairwells
a convection chimney forms elevator
shafts dumbwaiter shafts and laundry
chutes add their bit chiefly through
piston action the air current thus
created here shown by the movement of
smoke may be carried through an open
door it may pass over soiled linen down
the hall up and open stairwell the
current may carry it's bacteria to areas
where they are a real hazard the
problems of controlling air currents are
different in each hospital some can be
solved by a little care some may require
readjustment of ventilating equipment or
hospital design not all of our sepsis
problems are inanimate however the human
part of our environment perhaps presents
the most complex problem of all we are
all colonized we all scatter organisms
from our noses our skins in our perineum
some of us though apparently in good
health become multipliers and a source
of serious infection to others such
individuals certainly must not work
they can endanger patients they have no
place among hospital personnel there are
those who may have active skin
infections they too should absent
themselves while their infection is
communicable others who do not have
infections themselves may spread
bacteria from patient to patient this
could be an orderly who moments before
was emptying soiled laundry the number
of bacteria scattered from a healthy
nasal pharynx is of no great
significance but when the respiratory
tract becomes diseased bacteria multiply
several thousand percent
here is a sneeze in slow motion the
person has a cold
masks on a healthy person may be
adequate though typical masks are only
about 10% efficient when a person has an
upper respiratory infection masks are
totally inadequate masks soaked by
perspiration are no barriers to a cough
or sneeze
these are some of the problems that
every Hospital faces problems introduced
by the patient infected with resistant
organisms it is not hard to recognize
bacteria in a drawing as they're spread
by a mop it is easy to eliminate a
carrier by fading her out of a drawing
it is quite simple to state that we must
use care it is not so simple however to
deal with these complex practical
problems or even to see the septic
ferments in our own hospitals but once
we realize what our problems are the
trails of cross infection can be stopped
we can regulate pails and mops we can
supervise soiled linen we can sterilize
blankets and for my teas we can control
ventilation drinking water each item
that leave the septic room we can
emphasize hand-washing and personal
cleanliness we can develop ways of
isolating the infected patient the
techniques are available this is an
overall hospital problem everyone
contributes each of us must be willing
to supervise constantly and to be
supervised and above all each of us must
be able to see with his mental eye the
septic ferments
[Music]
[Music]